workers rights what hope for a more
social Europe our guest this week lino
Hoffman chairman of the German trade
union federation come on mr. Hoffman
your mother was a cleaning lady your
father a bricklayer you lead more than 6
million union members you speak
regularly with the Chancellor negotiate
with executives are you proud of
yourself designer it's an unusual career
I'll give you that when I look back at
my younger years I had no idea that I'd
one day be heading the German trade
union federation I'm not understood to
the store tomorrow for missus can you
get me idea you're considered a
pragmatist consensus minded is that the
right approach for someone spearheading
the country's labor movement with my
Daniel Hoffman tisha other I'm viola
given I think my ninety-three percent of
the vote speaks for itself at least
among the four hundred delegates of you
and being consensus minded means being
able to do both as needed social
partnership is based on strength not
weakness and when we have to we can play
by different rules to the anemia the van
you're taking over a well-oiled
organization and you can be pretty
satisfied with the current government
the Conservatives and the spdr both
catering to workers what's left for you
to do the pool give me plenty before
them quoted the policies in the
coalition contract and being introduced
as legislation or important reforms but
they're not nearly enough about does
hyphens not really provide some nice a
quarter of our workforce is stuck in a
low-wage sector 24 10 20 50 that's a
scandal for one of the richest nations
in the EU the opium on your on gundog we
need to revamp the labour market but
marked we need rules for temporary work
contracts we need to reform part-time
work and make the workplace more humane
how abide fukem tamannaah gustaria and
corn we need workers to have more of a
voice because we've seen that the
possibilities open to work a
representation on the shop floor won't
suffice to meet the future challenges of
Labor
all motion additional burdens and
factories and offices are presenting new
tasks for us and most of all we need a
change of course when it comes to Europe
people finding in the victim or open
invoice so even with the current
coalition there's lots for us to do gig
of our off my flesh about my image sign
of you but milestones including a higher
minimum wage and earlier retirement
benefits now possible from age 63 point
in a different direction namely to make
workers more comfortable 50s corpus
kitchen is normal it's not just about
comfort quote first of all these are
corrections that were badly needed the
problems date back to the shrowde
government that's 115 these corrections
are the first steps in that direction
above if we really want to raise the
status of Labor then it's not just about
raising the minimum wage one min this
going on so we have to strengthen
collective bargaining rights so that
employers and unions can negotiate
decent wages decent work hours and
decent conditions and factories and
offices Phaneuf [ __ ] aha bites side and
how that's not something a minimum wage
can achieve that's the lowest limit that
no one can be allowed to fall beneath
but we want more we want good work for
as many or for all people in this
country the Queen yo hook that you're
getting support from Chancellor Merkel
and from international organizations
that say wages should climb sharply in
Germany to further boost domestic demand
that's all grist for your milk bottle
filled moon does Vasa often it's grist
for the mill because Germany is the
export world champion laughs that's a
recognized fact but I can't survive long
term if we don't simultaneously have
strong domestic demand that helps boost
imports and over time compensate
macroeconomic imbalances especially
within the eurozone disrupted that's why
we're calling for demand side policy
combined with strong hikes in real
income balcony I'm comin through work
and not just for Germany
pilgrim we need a European growth
program so that the crisis-hit nations
of southern Europe get back in their
feet and here the policy of the former
center-right government was a complete
disaster it went in completely the wrong
direction then with the new German
government I think we still have a lot
of convincing to do so that European
policy gets back on the right track
we're doing that in the context of the
European elections on May twenty-fifth
we're going to use it when the new
European Commission is being chosen and
we're definitely going to call on the
new commission to introduce a change of
policy in Europe that's not just about
painful austerity without ignoring
necessary structural reforms bark was
all fought or a note when you go school
but the focus has to be on promoting
growth and therefore jobs good jobs
extrude ah mid / 50 on guitar but these
are don't say that so easily a growth
and investment program for Europe do you
have a master plan for the European debt
and financial crisis often if us with
your mouth I'm not claiming that we have
a master plan but at least we have the
better solutions which policymakers are
also listening to they include having
decent rules on international financial
markets the in town tomorrow don't
forget what caused the disastrous 2008
crisis it was the result of broadly
deregulated markets morning nine goofy
third part of the neoliberal mainstream
drag Europe and many other regions to
the edge of the abyss Martin other than
your evo Halep mainstream hardly changed
direction since then for instance with
the banking Union which will have new
rules I've smooth Pfizer macduncan when
you want of always more those are
important steps in the right direction
and we have to keep moving forward
doesn't your globe I think we're pretty
fit as trade unions I also recognize
with satisfaction that some of our
proposals for an international financial
market architecture are being taken up
Google from them that's an important
threshold moving forward however the key
will be to mark a new course for macro
economic policy in Europe on an encore
it's not enough for Europe to have a
mutual monetary policy
mind for which the European Central Bank
is responsible I'm fun we still lack a
common European fiscal policy and the
effect unfortunately has been that we
have fallen into a tax race in Europe
that's a race to the bottom it's not
helping economy stabilized by taking us
deeper into the hole if we don't hit the
break soon right Indian up corn food
will be done each feel Chris problems in
nineteen you think yeah I'm kind of you
know your way around brussels what's
your main demand there what has to
change across europe in the interests of
workers purely in person they are allied
nima hope our most in desert in europe
has to be strengthened in its social
dimension that includes finally giving
basic social rights precedence over
market freedoms why I that will convince
people mention they've lost their trust
in market deregulation mock they wanted
Europe with policies for people not from
markets and a politically mention only
feeding back to the motto and once
that's put into practice then trust in
the European integration project will
climb again to open to God's ones quick
rhythm and in the year 2014 we'd also be
well advised to look back forgive you
son World War one started a hundred
years ago we could not World War 2 75
years ago very quick from the petition
school tomorrow a very quick and then we
see what a huge piece project the EU is
and remains in European history about
more vital and we can wear this one's
good linked oakton but we can move
forward only if we succeed in putting
social peace in Europe on a firm footing
or the [ __ ] with food it's crumbling
nothing and that's why I fear that on
May twenty-fifth right-wing populists
anti-eu parties will make gains before
none of us wants that we must fight them
and to do that we need a change of
course toward a more social Europe I'm
course fix the English Premier so tialys
or oppa you're digging park your
counterpart is industry the factories
entrepreneurs and managers yeah they've
long been operating globally can unions
catch up and work on a global
scale oh they didn't give isn't mimesis
we are every bit as globalized as the
companies are it's just not always
visible for instance we have more than
1,200 works councils in Europe that
represent interests across borders in
multinational corporations interesting
photo from ending multi not through
nonconformity why we have a social
dialogue in which we've been able to get
some European rules back on the
negotiating table really going hard
often far north we go for I'm Bob it's
reached a standstill and has to be
reactivated via a Lada in the sectors we
have many European agreements when it
comes to improving working conditions at
both the national and European level to
which target and these are found we have
to communicate these experiences more
actively to the public as I said we're
very active even if people don't see
most of it it's a weak point we have to
work on and we will in the coming months
and years that's in the mahogany need
someone on yard licking your money but
in telemetry ond Europe to Latin America
Asia Africa how can you help minors or
garment workers in say Bangladesh visor
mid give actually holla at heaven Carter
Bangladesh is the her I'm guns
Bangladesh is a tragic example of how
work safety regulations are violated so
much that the core working norms of
international labor organizations are
negated the count Ovid's norm there is
no free labor movement there and there
we remind the cheapest German and
European corporations in wages and work
conditions of their obligations want an
indoor front o buying t-shirts for a
year of 50 selling them here for five
euros earning huge profits from
appalling conditions five six thousand
kilometers away from here the iron call
from foreign oil here fair call from the
leading perfect among us who would we
have to raise awareness of that thousand
six thousand kilometer phone we have to
think about the value of products not
just a work at all the feeling that
pinching pennies really can be deadly to
put it as we saw on the tragic garment
factory collapse in Bangladesh
zonin to design con either Indian he did
but in a farm in Bangladesh there's a
lot we're actively pursuing there with
the companies themselves from quicken
cuisine harm their social responsibility
doesn't end at national borders though
but a company social responsibility has
to be international global and we're
doing well in reminding businesses of
their responsibility moose internet soon
almost violent ones in figure many have
responded positively but many others are
dragging their heels on a good place to
park they still don't grasp the matter
and continue to reject work of
representation before it was it dortmund
amazon and burger king or two names
amazon orders conditions there we're
doing a good job of fighting them and
I'd say with some success oh why why mr.
Hoffman many thanks thank you